zu sagen herzlich willkommen zur zdf
heute live euren und ihren live stream
zu aktuellen ereignissen
und da schauen wir heute nach washington
denn die usa kommen einfach auch zwei
monate nach den präsidentschaftswahlen
nicht zur ruhe
noch präsident donald trump versucht mit
allen mitteln das ergebnis anzufechten
zahlreiche gerichtsprozesse hat er schon
verloren und heute ist ein ziemlich
wichtiger tag viele ereignisse finden
dort gerade parallel statt einmal wird
in georgia ausgezählt dort geht es in
einer stichwahl um zwei senatssitze die
für die demokraten ziemlich wichtig sind
parallel dazu wird aber in washington im
senat im kongress ausgezählt oder wird
zertifiziert die das ergebnis der wahl
leute die über den präsidenten der
vereinigten staaten abgestimmt haben das
ist ein eigentlich eher pro forma
prozess wo noch einmal durchgezählt wird
und das anerkannt wird wie die wahlleute
angestimmt haben aber auch dort gibt es
widerstand aus den reihen der
republikaner und draußen vor dem
kongress stehen tausende von trump
anhängern und mein kollege elmar
theveßen der das ganze für uns
beobachtet und die stimmung scheint sehr
gereizt zu sein
matti wissen was kannst du uns da sagen
ja das kann man sagen aufgewiegelt vom
amerikanischen präsidenten vorher hinter
dem weißen haus wo sich zehntausende von
demonstranten versammelt haben sind die
demonstranten hierhergezogen zum kapitol
und versuchen das kongress gebäude zu
stürmen wir werfen einen blick hier auf
die seite hinter mir das ist die
ostseite des kapitols in washington vor
hin kamen tausende von demonstranten
hierher sind an die eingangstreppe des
kapitols gelangt die polizei hat sie
zunächst an der untersten stufe zurück
gehalten dann hat sich aus
unerfindlichen gründen die polizei
zurückgezogen bis oben auf die oberste
stufe in den eingangsbereich wir sehen
jetzt dass da hunderte von demonstranten
stehen
schlimmer noch ist es auf der anderen
seite der westside
das kongresses dort sind ja bereits die
tribünen aufgebaut für die inauguration
die amtseinführung die in zwei wochen
stattfinden soll
wir haben gerade erfahren dass innerhalb
der letzten minuten die demonstranten
also auf der anderen seite des kapitols
die linie der polizei durchbrochen haben
sie sind ebenfalls hinauf gestürmt und
die große frage ist ob sie in der lage
sind in das gebäude einzudringen und
möglicherweise die laufenden sitzungen
von abgeordnetenhaus und senat zu stören
wir wissen auch dass in nachbargebäuden
hier um uns herum bereits alle
mitarbeiter aufgefordert wurden also die
mitarbeiter der amerikanischen
kongressabgeordneten aufgefordert wurden
ihre büros zu verlassen durch die tunnel
an fluchtpunkte zu gehen also die lage
sei eskaliert ein stückweit aufgewiegelt
vom amerikanischen präsidenten
man merkt die stimmung ist aufgeladen
also es gibt noch keine
ich sag mal gewalttätigen
ausschreitungen
obwohl es schon rangeleien mit der
polizei auf der anderen seite des
kapitols vor hingegeben hat ich habe mal
auf twitter gesucht was es da einen
videos gibt ich habe einige gefunden das
schalten immer auf meinen rechner und
können die einmal anspielen das sind
dann doch sehen die ziemlich
besorgniserregend aussehen so was hier
zum beispiel vor einer stunde gefunden
das kann auch schon rabiat aus wo du
zeit fragen das einigermaßen der
abstimmung erstellenden halten ist die
international versuchen wieder diese
absterben dritter zu kommen es gibt für
fast schon gespürt
anschließend war die kartenansicht die
macht scheint derzeit das alkersleben
können
aber es gibt auch das zeigt wieviele
menschen auf das kapitol zu geben
und ja dabei sein quasi zum 10
hier so aus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
natürlich ist es für uns vor ort in
washington auf der seite wo gerade jetzt
nicht so viel los ist aber ich glaube
wahrscheinlich hörst du auch dass die
stimmung aufgeheizt ist du hast das
einfach gesagt präsident trump hat die
menge aufgewiegelt was meinst du damit
ja er hat sich vor hinter das weiße haus
begeben auf die sogenannte ellipse an
der großen malls
dort hat er zu den menschen gesprochen
und hat gesagt wir werden niemals
aufgeben wir werden niemals die
niederlage eingestehen wir werden nicht
akzeptieren dass die demokraten das land
übernehmen
und er hat dann auch aufgefordert oder
gesagt wir werden die pennsylvania
avenue entlang marschieren zum kapitol
ob er damit meinte dass er selber auch
hierher kommen will das ist noch offen
aber er hat ganz offenbar damit bewirkt
dass die demonstranten wie gesagt
zehntausende von ihnen hier hergekommen
sind zum kapitol ganz offensichtlich
waren die sicherheitskräfte darauf nicht
vorbereitet in den brunnen im capitol
laufen ja derzeit die beratungen es sind
ja als er einspruch erhoben worden gegen
einzelne zertifizierungen aus einzelnen
bundesstaaten es wird also debattiert
auskommt möglicherweise der punkt wo aus
sicherheitsgründen dann diese sitzungen
abgebrochen werden müssten
es kommt vielleicht auch der punkt wo
die polizei wo die sicherheitskräfte
entscheiden hier das ganze gelände rund
um das kapitol zu räumen
das gefährlichste daran ist
möglicherweise dass in der menschenmenge
hier nicht nur viele menschen sind die
sagen normal wütend und ärgerlich sind
die aber ich sage mal mit gewalt nicht
unbedingt etwas zu tun haben sondern die
menschen in dieser menge die bereit sind
zur gewalt zb milizen die eigentlich
auch bewaffnete milizen sind ihnen ist
verboten worden hier in washington dc
waffen zu tragen es wurde auch
kontrolliert gestern aber bei diesen
menschenmassen ist es unmöglich zu
kontrollieren ob vielleicht doch waffen
mitgebracht worden sind von milizen wie
den traut beispielsweise die haben wir
vorhin zu hunderten hier an uns vorbei
marschieren sehen also es besteht die
gefahr dass aus dieser menge heraus
tatsächlich gewalt ausgeübt wird und das
ganze dann eben auch weiter eskaliert
ich bekomme jetzt hier gerade in unserem
agentur system die ersten meldungen dass
das gebäude des us kongresses ist das
kapitol im lock down ist und dass ich ja
quasi die debatte vertagt wird wir
müssen mal schauen immer was du da
gleich vielleicht auch noch mit bekommst
wir wollen aber einmal ganz kurz anhören
was präsident trump heute vor wenigen
stunden ich glaube vor zwei stunden war
es ungefähr in seiner rede an seine
anhänger gesagt hat wir alle hier wollen
nicht dass unser wahlsieg von den
radikalen linken demokraten gestohlen
wird das tun sie wir aber werden nie
aufgeben und ich habe gerade die
bestätigung bekommen von meinen kollegen
hier in mainz die das ganze natürlich
auch beobachten dass die debatte über
die stimmen des elektro college also
über die wahlausgang der wahlmänner
abgebrochen wurde wegen der ereignisse
im capitol ich sehe immer du schaust
auch gerade noch mal was du an
informationen bekommst wir können jetzt
einfach nur weiter abwarten wie das
ganze ab wie sich weiterentwickelt das
ist natürlich eine ziemlich
besorgniserregende situation denn so was
haben die usa glaube ich so noch nie
erlebt einmal oder nein so was haben die
vereinigten staaten glaube ich noch
nicht erlebt wir hören hier explosionen
wir wissen nicht genau was diese
explosionen sind wir wissen das vorhin
evakuiert wurde einige gebäude rund um
das kapitol mit hinweis darauf dass
möglicherweise eine rohrbombe gefunden
worden sei
das ist aber noch nicht offiziell
bestätigt solche szenen hat es hier am
kapitol nach meiner erinnerung
eigentlich noch nie gegeben bestenfalls
vielleicht in den jahren nach dem
amerikanischen bürgerkrieg 1876 gab es
schon einmal eine sehr umstrittene wahl
da drohte auch gewalt am ende hat man
sich dann untereinander verständigt wer
der neue präsident werden würde aber das
was wir hier erleben das kennt man
vielleicht aus ländern
ich sag mal die man als
bananenrepubliken bezeichnet wird
der autoritäre regime und diktaturen und
hier ist ein präsident der ganz offenbar
sich an die spitze dieser bewegung sende
ersetzt es gibt eine befürchtung
und die kommt nicht einfach irgendwo
wird aus der luft gegriffen sondern die
haben zehn ehemalige
verteidigungsminister in den vergangenen
tagen ja in einer öffentlichen erklärung
in der washington post dann tatsächlich
auch der öffentlichkeit präsentiert sie
befürchten dass der amerikanische
präsident wäre bereit wäre hier so etwas
wie chaos zu erzeugen den notstand
auszurufen und das amerikanische militär
zu seiner unterstützung herbei zu rufen
die verteidigungsminister die ehemaligen
darunter auch einige republikanische
verteidigungsminister haben ganz klar
gesagt das darf nicht passieren das wäre
ein angriff auf die demokratie das
militär dürfte dabei nicht mitmachen
man glaubt gar nicht dass man über so
etwas überhaupt reden muss im
zusammenhang mit einer amerikanischen
demokratie die ja vorbild ist für viele
nationen rund um den erdball für viele
menschen die amerikanischen ideale von
demokratie und freiheit aber wenn man
das hier erlebt was wir hier heute
morgen schon gesehen haben und west was
jetzt gerade passiert dann schließt man
nicht mehr aus dass in den nächsten
wochen chaotische szenen auf die straßen
hier in washington oder anderswo
bestimmen könnten in zwei wochen wäre
die amtseinführung und das hoffen
jedenfalls natürlich die menschen in den
usa die große mehrheit die beiden
gewählt hat das alles darf die
amtseinführung nicht gefährden nach der
amerikanischen verfassung wird sie am 20
januar 2021 um 12 uhr mittags
stattfinden dann erlischt die amtszeit
von dort donald trump beginnt die neue
amtszeit von joe biden egal ob das nun
hier oder anderswo geschieht die frage
ist ob der präsident der amtierende
präsident bereit ist alles zu tun um
seine macht zu erhalten so ich schaue
jetzt mal hier auf twitter gibt es
tatsächlich erste bilder dass
demonstranten versuchen ins kapitol zu
gelingen gelangen also wirklich ganz nah
dran ist sollte man auch meinen
bildschirm
also wirklich den nächsten tagen
jedenfalls ruder
denn für
direkt vor dem titel
bis jetzt
diese techniken
[Applaus]
was wir tatsächlich
klassierten sich aber das ganze eine
gesagt außergewöhnliche und ziemlich
besorgniserregende situation wenn wir
nochmal die gegner uns anschauen
die vor ungefähr einer stunde zu uns
gedrungen sind auch über twitter das
sieht dann doch sehr handgreiflich
aggressiv aus die stimmung dort vor dem
kapitol das ganze wie gesagt jetzt
ungefähr eine stunde her
die polizei scheint sich zurückgezogen
es gibt es nach den athlon ii gerade
gesehen haben keine polizei banken die
jetzt versuchen dort die menschen vor
den türen wegzuhalten ich würde
vorschlagen
matthäus in washington vor ort das zudem
einen überblick über die lage
verschaffen was du dort herausfinden
kann sind wir gleich wieder zu dir
schalten weil wir werden auf jeden fall
jetzt erstmal dabei bleiben und schauen
wie sich die lage in washington weiter
entwickelt parallel zu diesen
ereignissen in washington wo der
kongress also die beiden kammern des
kongresses senat und repräsentantenhaus
über die ergebnisse des elektro college
es also der wahlleute beraten und
eigentlich ist das eine pro forma sache
das wird dann einfach weitergemacht wird
gesagt alles klar so wurde abgestimmt
der nächste präsident ist der den ihr
gewählt habt das scheint heute nicht der
fall zu sein aber parallel zu diesem ja
doch sehr wichtigen ereignis gibt es in
georgia eine stichwahl beziehungsweise
gab es gestern ausgezählt wird aber
immer noch und dort geht es um zwei
senatssitze die sind relativ wichtig für
die demokraten und was das ganze mit
einander zu tun hat das hat meine
kollegin ina niebergall mal für uns
auseinander gedrosselt regieren ohne
große widerstände aus dem us-kongress
darum geht es für die regierung von joe
biden und camilla herrem
und alles hängt an zwei sitzen im senat
der sieht nämlich aktuell so aus einer
der beiden sitze ist bereits an den
demokratischen kandidaten aus georgia
gefallen
der andere noch offen nun gibt es zwei
optionen geht der sitz an die
republikaner haben sie die mehrheit geht
er aber nie demokraten gibt es ein patt
50 zu 50
dann kann laut us-verfassung
vize-präsidentin harris mit ihrer stimme
eine mehrheit herstellen für die
demokraten
für die demokratische regierung von
beiden und harris ist das entscheidend
denn im repräsentantenhaus haben die
demokraten schon die mehrheit neue
gesetze brauchen aber die zustimmung
beider kongresskammern auch der haushalt
wird von repräsentantenhaus und senat
verabschiedet der senat muss außerdem
zustimmen wenn der us-präsident posten
neu besetzen will minister richter und
botschafter zum beispiel sind
präsidentschaft repräsentantenhaus und
senat in der hand einer partei kann die
us-regierung mehr oder weniger
durchregieren gesetze einfacher
verabschieden posten unkomplizierter
besetzen ist das aber nicht so muss sich
der präsident um immer neue mehrheiten
bemühen gesetze haushaltsentwürfe
könnten vom senat blockiert werden für
beiden und harris hängt also viel an den
beiden senat sitzen aus georgia
also eine extrem wichtige wahl und
extrem wichtige stunden in der
geschichte der vereinigten staaten von
amerika und darüber möchte ich jetzt
sprechen mit kathrin klug
politikwissenschaftlerin in der
universität von harvard schönen guten
abend carlo und nach meinen sie sehen
diese bilder wahrscheinlich auch gerade
parallel im internet in den sozialen
medien jetzt mal tatsächlich so als
politikwissenschaftlerin haben sie so
was schon mal erlebt beziehungsweise
auch kommen sehen nein hätte wissen hat
es schon angesprochen also als solches
ist das ein historisches novum für die
usa hätte man es kommen sehen können ist
eine andere frage denn zu der strategie
des präsidenten gehörte schon vor der
wahl der angekündigte straßen kann
wir haben uns schon um den dritten
november darüber gedanken gemacht ob es
gegebenenfalls noch größere
auseinandersetzungen auf den straßen der
jeweiligen bundesstaaten geben könnte ob
es da schon waren zu radikalisierter und
rechts radikalisierter gewalt kommen
könnte eine studie hat kurz vor der wahl
bestätigt dass die rechtsradikale gewalt
also ja quasi sich als unterdrückt
empfundenen weißen inzwischen fast
minderheit in den usa intern die größte
bedrohung ist also der interne
terrorismus der größten die größte
bedrohung für die sicherheit amerikas
sein könnte und wenn man die bilder
natürlich jetzt sieht dann empfindet man
das zumindest persönlich ganz genau so
sind durchaus bedrohlich im bilde
ich kann jetzt mal einfach weiter auf
twitter schalten wir haben hier ein bild
von ego bobic das ist ein politik
reporter der washington post der
tatsächlich ein bild zeigt wie protester
protest protestierende
hier sehen wir es im kongress sind
polizei steht dort versucht sie
aufzuhalten wir haben auch andere bilder
gerade schon gesehen dass menschen vor
den türen sind also tatsächlich eine
außergewöhnliche besorgniserregende
entwicklung fue facebook was ist denn
tatsächlich das ziel dieser
protestierenden also wollen sie
tatsächlich also glauben sie tatsächlich
meinen sie dass sie die wahl des
präsidenten noch umswitchen können wer
ich glaube der eigentliche hauptgedanke
ist jetzt erstmal so viel diskussionen
so viel durcheinander
zu erzeugen dass es quasi nicht zu den
von der verfassung gegebenen prozessen
kommen kann
hertie wir sind hat das schon gut
erklärt wie ihr eigentlich nun die
ganzen diskussionen innerhalb des
kongresses in diesen zwei kammern senat
und kongress eigentlich hätte vorgehen
müssen auch wenn es eben die den den
einspruch arizonas gegeben hat oder über
die stimmen arizona so ging der prozess
nämlich heute morgen los
sie versuchen natürlich erst mal soviel
ja sagen wir unmut zu erzeugen
die straßen weiter aufgeheizt zu
behalten und sie folgen dem aufruf ihres
präsidenten wir hatten den einspieler
vorhin schon das sind die botschaften
die dieser präsident schon seit monaten
an seinen wahl volk an seiner
unterstützer herantrat und in er in der
ersten linie wird es irgendwie gesagt
darum gehen den normalen von der
verfassung vorgesehenen prozess zu
behindern mit der hoffnung natürlich
dass irgendwas ändern würde aber das
wird vermutlich nicht der fall
jetzt ist doch eine frage die sich viele
menschen in deutschland immer wieder
stellen und den letzten zwei monaten
erst recht die konnte es so weit kommen
dass die usa in dieser lage sind in
dieser verfassung sind dass ein
amtierender noch präsident seine abwahl
nicht anerkennt und seine anhänger jetzt
soweit aufstachelt dass sie bereit sind
tatsächlich die wichtigsten gebäude in
washington im herz der amerikanischen
demokratie zu stürmen ja ich mache mir
große sorgen um die verfasstheit der
amerikanischen demokratie aber das ist
und insofern sind vielleicht diese
bilder neben seiner doch etwas
überraschend es ist ein angriff mit
ansage wir haben ganz ähnliche bilder
noch im kopf vom state house in michigan
wo auch bewaffnete anhänger von donald
trump eben auch anhänger verschiedener
weißer milizen das date haus gestürmt
haben wir in uns an den coo gegen oder
den vermutlichen geplanten juan oder den
ja das kidnapping der gouverneurin von
michigan
das sind alles als zeichen einer
aufgeputschten eines aufgepeitschten
landes und das entspricht alles der
strategie dieses präsidenten also immer
wieder die legitimität eines
demokratischen wahlprozesses
frage zu stellen das ist ja keine neue
strategie das ist nicht erst die
strategie des präsidenten salz 20 19 20
20 sondern das hatte er sogar schon 20
16 im wahlkampf immer wieder betont dass
im amerikanischen wahlrecht nicht zu
trauen sei das wenn er verlöre das
natürlich nicht rechten dingen zugehen
und so weiter und so fort
diese indes informationen anders kann
man das gar nicht beschreiben aber
natürlich auf großer und breit
angelegter art und zwar von denen
inzwischen größten fernsehkanälen in den
usa zum teil verströmt nämlich eben von
fox news als extrem gespaltene medium
oder den der ins extrem gespalten
medienwelt in den usa immer wieder
verbreitet
das hat sich inzwischen fest gesetzt und
ist für und das hat eben auch betont
auch für menschen quasi er in der mitte
oder die sich dem traditionellen
republikanischen spektrum zuordnen
würden hat zumindest dazu geführt dass
sie sich fragen stellen 70 prozent der
amerika der republikaner zweifeln
inzwischen diese wahl die legitimität
dieser wahl an und da hängt vieles mit
der medienlandschaft in den usa zusammen
aber eben auch mit dem was der präsident
wie gesagt nicht erst bei den letzten
jahren sondern seit über vier jahren in
die bevölkerung streut aber da ist auch
wenn die frage scheint trump in
anführungszeichen doch etwas richtig zu
machen beziehungsweise einen nerv
getroffen zu haben wenn so viele
menschen bereit sind ihren institutionen
und ihre medien zu misstrauen
das ist ein langer und schleichender
prozess aber was sie ansprechen ist das
mangelnde grundvertrauen amerikaner
untereinander und das ist ein prozess
den verfolgen soziologen schon seit
geraumer zeit fast 30 jahren nimmt auch
das interpersonelle vertrauen was er
natürlich der grundstein einer
funktionierenden demokratie ist ja aber
das vertrauen an
in seinem nachbarn zum beispiel immer
wieder stetig an also das grundvertrauen
ineinander das ist in amerika gestört
das sehen wir in anderen industriellen
ländern auch dass in deutschland auch
aber der verfall und der schnelle
verfall an vertrauen in institutionen an
funktionalität von demokratie gerade an
den an den großen institutionen also wir
denken eben an kongress und das amt des
präsidenten dass darunter ein drittel
der amerikaner wirklich b auf das was
das das prinzip hält als besonders auch
natürlich unter jüngeren jüngeren
amerikanern das ist ein großes
interpersonelle misstrauen und einen
misstrauen gegenüber den institutionen
gibt das ist ein schleichender prozess
gewesen in den usa aber das ist über die
letzten vier jahre nämlich durch diesen
raubbau den wirklichen raubbau den umbau
des justizsystems das immer und wieder
hervorkehren bediente bilder dass der
präsident gegen den sogenannten tiefen
staat vorgehen wollen würde das ist
dadurch nur noch also diese
unsicherheiten in der bevölkerung nur
noch verstärkt was kann das sein fragt
über spruch dass das ein land dem ist ja
verhältnismäßig gut geht also im
globalen vergleich dass die weltmacht
nummer eins ist auf der ganzen welt ja
willi tierisch auch vertreten mächtig in
der wirtschaft dass die menschen sich
dort in den letzten 30 jahren immer
weniger vertraut haben
amerika ist hat einen tiefen umbau
prozess durchgemacht über die letzten 30
jahre wir haben eine
deindustrialisierung erlebt zeitgleich
haben wir natürlich dann dadurch
verschiedene strömungen in der
demografie erlebt also einerseits ein
abbau kernindustrien in den usa
andererseits eine erweiterung zum
beispiel von minderheitsrechte das hat
wiederum viele menschen auf den teppich
gerufen die wir jetzt eben auch von mir
vor dem kapitol sehen die ihr ganzes
grundverständnis von recht und ordnung
die stabilisiert dmg sehen die erwartet
dass die erweiterung von
minderheitenrechten ihre
persönlichkeitsrechte kommt wir denken
an die legalisierung der
gleichgeschlechtlichen ehe und die
proteste die das hervorgerufen hat und
gerade auch die prozesse in den
einzelnen bundesstaaten das zeigt dass
eben diese vielen tiefen
umwälzungsprozess in der gesellschaft
doch dafür gesorgt haben dass ganz
grundsätzliche prozesse der demokratie
nämlich das rechte ständig erweitert
werden müssen dass demokratie das ist in
einer demokratie gilt immer mehr
menschen gleichzustellen in die gleichen
möglichkeiten zu schaffen dass das nicht
mehr als grundlage dieses demokratischen
systems so empfunden wird als das über 3
50 millionen amerikaner danach groß
daran glauben würden wir haben kurz über
die jüngere generation gesprochen dann
noch einen punkt dazu das ist eine
generation die tief verunsichert ist das
sind junge menschen die um den 11
september geboren worden sind für die
terrorismus das erst sind die ersten
paar jahre ihres lebens bestimmt haben
und dann zwei extrem langer historisch
lange kriege für die usa in der gerade
sie haben angesprochen die
wirtschaftsstärke den usa aber zwei wir
denken an die wirtschaftskrise 2008 2009
für dann für die ist dann auf einmal in
der familie wirklich schwierig wurde
kann kann man einen teil existenzen eine
mittelklasse gehalt und eine
mittelklasse existenz den mittelstand
kann man den halten diese großen
veränderungsprozesse die haben wir zum
beispiel in deutschland nicht oder noch
nicht so mitgemacht weil urs
globalisierung anders betroffen hat also
in einem flächen starken land in dem
große generelle demografische
unterschiede zu diagnostizieren sind die
wie in europa so nicht kennen haben
diese quasi aufeinander treffenden
effekte dafür gesorgt dass eben nicht
nur eine jüngere generation aber ein
ganzes land doch durchaus sehr
verunsichert ist also findet die gerade
erst zu schalten was wir eigentlich
heute machen wollten ist mal schauen wie
es in den usa aussieht wie es mit der
abstimmung oder der debatte im kongress
in washington zum wahlergebnis über die
präsidentschaftswahl aussieht und was
wir heute aber erleben müssen jetzt zur
stunde ist dass tausende von jobs
reportern von jab anhängern um das
kapitel sich herum versammelt haben dass
es menschen gelungen ist in das kapitol
vorzudringen
und wir sprechen damit gleich weiter mit
frau prüfer spruch
politikwissenschaftlerin die uns
hoffentlich noch ein bisschen begleitet
wird wollen jetzt aber nochmal zu elmar
theveßen nach washington schalten der
live vor ort ist am kongress und uns
vielleicht sagen kann wie die lage jetzt
gerade bei ihm aussieht
ja es gibt ein paar neue entwicklungen
hier am kapitol normalen blick drauf
werfen hinter uns die demonstranten
haben die obersten stufen des
haupteingangs des kapitols besetzt
teilweise auch auf der webseite des
repräsentantenhauses hinten haben
anderen ende des gebäudes ähnlich sieht
es auf der anderen seite des kapitols
aus man hat vize-präsident pence in
sicherheit gebracht zunächst innerhalb
des capitol gebäudes es kann sein dass
er auch bereits aus dem kapitol heraus
das capitol verlassen hat aus
sicherheitsgründen und hier an der seite
neben uns ist gerade polizei in großer
zahl auf marschiert mit helmen mit
entsprechenden schutzwesten
möglicherweise könnte es in den nächsten
minuten hier ein räumungsversuch geben
weil das ganze natürlich als eine
bedrohung auch für den amerikanischen
kongress angesehen wird die
bürgermeisterin von washington hat jetzt
vor wenigen minuten für heute abend eine
ausgangssperre ab sechs uhr abends hier
in washington verhängt die ganz strikt
auch durchgesetzt werden soll
das heißt man will versuchen dass die
zehntausende von demonstranten jump
anhänger in erster linie dass die die
stadt vor 6 uhr verlassen oder in ihr
hotel zimmer zurückkehren weil man sorge
hat dass es hier bei einbruch der
dunkelheit zu großen ausschreitungen in
den straßen kommen könnte
wir wissen nicht ob man diese situation
hier so lösen kann
wir sehen dass eine reihe von
demonstranten auch weggehen das sind
besonders ich sage nur familien mit
kindern die hier mit dabei waren ältere
menschen die den ort des geschehens
jetzt gerade hier verlassen
aber der kern der demonstranten der
tramp anhänger nicht nur auf dieser
seite des kapitols sondern auch auf der
anderen seite des kapitols sind weiter
da und jene unter ihnen sind eben
hunderte von milizionären milizionären
entschuldigung die möglicherweise auch
willens wären gewalt hier in washington
anzuwenden also die situation ist
weiterhin sehr sehr aufgeladen sehr
angespannt wir werden das in den
nächsten minuten hier weiter beobachten
wir wissen dass die sitzung im kongress
wohl unterbrochen worden ist weil man
zunächst einmal für die sicherheit auch
der kongressabgeordneten sorgen will
aber eine lösung ist nicht in sicht der
amerikanische präsident gießt weiterhin
parallel dazu öl ins feuer er twittert
diese tweets werden teilweise hier auch
von den demonstranten
dann fühlen sie sich ermutigt also ist
eine situation die wir wir haben ja
schon darüber geredet in den usa seit
vielen vielen jahrzehnten genauer gesagt
eigentlich seit 1876 so nicht erlebt
haben und da kann ich es kaum dass das
möglich ist aber dass ein amerikanischer
präsident gewissermaßen eine erstürmung
einer demokratischen einrichtung
befeuert und aufwiegelt dazu das glaube
ich haben sich wenige vorstellen können
wenn wir da kann ich vielleicht den
aktuellsten tweets von donald trump kurz
zeigen der jetzt dazu aufgerufen hat
dass die demonstranten friedlich bleiben
hier habe ich noch mal auf dem
bildschirm gelegt please support aber
kapitän verließ and law enforcement also
bitte unterstützt die kapitel polizei
und unsere restlichen polizei derart
julian der site of other countries sind
auf der seite unseres landes tsv also
bleibt friedlich
aber wir sehen darunter auch gleich
schon die antworten an ihn das sind
nämlich also mit dem vorwurf des orion
daran dass du schuld denn es gibt bilder
von menschen die gern mehr abitur sind
alle mit einem feuerlöscher um sich ja
sie sagten einmal zu schießen kann den
ausgelöst haben also nach unten gibt es
weitere bilder von menschen im capitol
hier zum beispiel haben wir schon
gesehen habe ich schon mal gezeigt ein
foto aber auch weitere bilder wie
menschen dort die treppenstufen hoch
gehen und die polizei erstmal ihnen auch
der tatsächlich den raum lässt mit
erhobenen händen geht dort ein
effektiver mann flüchtig länger und die
polizei hat er jo sind hier gern nichts
ihn aufzuhalten
kontrovers haben zahlreiche menschen und
versuchen daniel ich kann sie nicht
hören weil der ton so laut ist von den
videos okay ich habe sie erst mal
angehalten
meine frage doch noch an an dich immer
es sieht jetzt hinter dir relativ
friedlich auch muss ich sagen für wie
bedrohlich hältst du denn die situation
tatsächlich gerade ja ich glaube je mehr
menschen weg gehen die nichts mit gewalt
eigentlich zu tun haben wollen desto
mehr konzentriert sich die gruppe eben
auf die die absolut dazu bereit wären es
ist vorstellbar dass das weiter
eskaliert es hat offenbar mindestens an
einer stelle auch ein eindringen von
demonstranten ins kapitol gegeben
die polizei das sehen wir hier verstärkt
weiter ihre kräfte und wir glauben dass
auch ein tränen gras tränengaseinsatz
möglich ist jetzt gegen die
demonstranten
ich sag jetzt mal ich war bei einigen
demonstrationen das was man hier riecht
und was man teilweise auch schon sieht
macht vorstellbar dass es schon an einer
stelle des kapitals auf der anderen
seite eingesetzt worden ist um hier zu
räumen
das spricht sich natürlich schnell unter
den demonstranten rum das würde auch
erklären warum
doch relativ viele dutzende immer wieder
hier in größeren gruppen an uns
vorbeikommen und weggehen aber der harte
kern das sind eben vor allen dingen
diese milizionäre die sind hierher nach
washington gekommen weil sie schlicht
und ergreifend ihrem frust freien lauf
lassen wollen
das spannende ist tatsächlich wir leben
in einer zeit als der social media es
sind viele reporter viele kollegen von
uns vor ort im capitol selber und
deswegen kriegen wir quasi minütlich
updates ich habe hier mal auf meinem
bildschirm gelegt stevenson dc -report
new york post
und er hat ein bild getwittert und
schreibt dazu der sf petrin tram prozess
zwischen capitol prophezeit mcdonald's
office until the last stand barth
problem ist der protest des coming from
or directions dazu dieses foto also
polizei behält die polizei die
offenkundig vor dem büro des
republikanischen mehrheitsführers im
senat stehen und versuchen dort gegen
die demonstranten vorzugehen
dort sehen wir ein anderes video auch
vom kollegen stephen mehr was
interessant ist ja was interessant ist
daniel weil vorhin der mehrheitsführer
im senat mitch mcconnell tatsächlich
eine flammende rede für seine
verhältnisse allerdings in sehr
zurückhaltender form aber mit sehr
starken worten gehalten hat gegen den
tribalismus gegen das sektierertum gegen
quasi stammesdenken innerhalb der usa
hat dafür plädiert dass man sich heute
hier einig sein sollte im capitol und
die wahl von joe biden bestätigen müsse
weil er diese wahl gewonnen habe und
donald trump eben nicht das ist ich
glaube die stärkste variante die wir
bisher tatsächlich von mitch mcconnell
gehört haben dass er ganz klar sagt der
neue präsident ist joe biden und
ausgerechnet der wird jetzt natürlich
auch zum ziel der demonstranten
wir haben teilweise auch vorhin als mike
pence der vizepräsident sich geweigert
hat im capitol die anerkennung zu
verweigern für verschiedene wahl
männerstimmen ergebnisse aus einzelnen
bundesstaaten hat gesagt er habe kein
recht dazu als vizepräsident was auch
stimmt nach der verfassung kann er das
nicht das hat er auch ganz heute ganz
klar gemacht heute und das wird als
verrat angesehen viele sehen das als
verrat des vize-präsidenten am
präsidenten an
also auch da geht eine spaltung sowohl
durch die regierung als eben auch durch
die republikanische partei weil im
kongress wohin
bei der sitzung auch eine reihe von
senatoren und abgeordneten sich eben
gegen die wahlergebnisse gerichtet haben
da ist ein tiefer graben zwischen
abgeordneten der republikanischen partei
entstanden und ob das heute hier noch zu
einer abstimmung kommen wird das ist
völlig offen
ich schaue mich noch einmal um wir sehen
dass weiterhin menschen das gelände hier
verlassen und wir haben gerade auch hier
eine notfall hinweis bekommen von der
stadtregierung von washington neben das
was ich vorhin schon einmal an spar das
heute abend eine ausgangssperre verhängt
ist ab sechs uhr abends das hat die
bürgermeisterin von washington dc vorhin
veranlasst das müsste eigentlich jeder
der ein handy dabei hat jetzt auch
bekommen und auch das könnte erklären
warum der eine oder andere demonstrant
hier jetzt den ort des geschehens
verlässt
für alle die gerade erst zugeschaltet
haben noch einmal ganz kurz die
zusammenfassung was derzeit passiert
eigentlich sollte in washington heute ja
ein proforma ein proforma vorgang im
capitol stattfinden die beiden kammern
des kongresses wollten die ergebnisse
des der wahlleuten der wahlmänner und
wahlfrauen abstimmung über die wahl des
neuen präsidenten joe biden diskutieren
das ist eigentlich ja mittlerweile ein
wohl ein geübtes ritual bei dem nicht
damit gerechnet wird dass sich
tatsächlich etwas an den wahlausgang
ändert aber donald trump hat eine rede
gehalten gegen 17 uhr unserer zeit in
der nähe des kapitols hat eine seiner
üblichen reden gehalten muss man sagen
und unter anderem seine anhänger dazu
aufgefordert zum kapitol zu ziehen die
sind dem nachgekommen und es gibt jetzt
berichte und auch bilder dass zahlreiche
menschen in das kapitol eingedrungen
sind und dass die diskussion über genau
diese abstimmung der wahlleute
abgebrochen werden musste das ganze
kapitel ist im lock down und polizei
haben wir da der gehört von unseren
korrespondenten vor ort herr matti
wissen ist dabei wahrscheinlich gleich
ins gebäude einzudringen eventuell mit
dem versuch das gebäude zu räumen
ich habe hier weitere bilder von white
house correspondents die dort vor ort
sind hier zum beispiel jasmin oder die
ist
im capitol und ihr sie schreibt es ihr
gesagt wo sie das auch demonstranten in
den dritten stock vorgedrungen sind das
hier ist ihre sicht gerade aus dem
fenster heraus also zahlreiche menschen
die sich dort versammelt haben und von
der polizei nichts mehr geräumt werden
können
du hast gerade schon erzählt diese
auseinandersetzung zwischen mike pence
dem vize-präsidenten und donald trump
ich glaube dass nicht jeder so im blick
ist unter so verfolgt hat was dort
passiert ist kannst du das noch mal
genauer erläutern also was hat donald
trump quasi versucht die hat er versucht
auch mike pence druck auszuüben und
wieso mike pence der vizepräsident hat
nach der amerikanischen verfassung
normalerweise bei dieser beglaubigung
der wahlergebnisse er eine zeremonielle
aufgabe das heißt er muss tatsächlich
die umschläge entgegennehmen er muss die
stimmen aus den einzelnen bundesstaaten
auszählen
das macht er noch nicht mal selber so
dass machen natürlich helfer für ihn
und dann muss er das ergebnis
bekanntgeben wer darf eigentlich gar
keinen einspruch einlegen aber genau das
hat donald trump von ihm gefordert in
den letzten tagen und wochen immer
wieder
es muss wohl hinter den kulissen im
weißen haus zu einer klaren
auseinandersetzung auch gekommen sein
zwischen ihm und mike büskens hat
öffentlich immer ein bisschen den
anschein erweckt als würde er an diesem
tag vielleicht doch dafür sorgen dass
eben der amerikanische präsident seinen
willen bekommt aber er hat das am ende
dann nicht getan hat einen langen brief
geschrieben hier an den amerikanischen
kongress und das vorhin auch im kongress
noch einmal sehr klar gemacht dass er
nicht glaubt dass er das recht hat nach
der amerikanischen verfassung gegen die
wahlmänner stimmen gegen die ergebnisse
aus den eigenen einzelnen bundesstaaten
tatsächlich einspruch einzulegen es wäre
ja auch eigentlich abstrus dass
ausgerechnet das mitglied einer
abgewählten regierung in der lage wäre
ein wahlergebnis zu annullieren das
gewissermaßen ihm nachteile bietet weil
er eben das amt verlassen müsste das
kann nicht der sinn der amerikanischen
verfassung sein also mike pence hat sich
daran gehalten
das wird ihnen sicherlich nicht die
freude von donald trump eintragen und
ganz besonders auch nicht von den
demonstranten hier der nazi wir heute
morgen hier ankamen
und als kurz danach dann auch mike pence
hier ankam an den demonstranten vorbei
fuhr mit seiner mit seiner kolonne
wagenkolonne da brandet die hier schon
ein stück weit jubel auf weil man eben
dachte er würde einspruch einlegen gegen
die ergebnisse aus den bundesstaaten
jetzt hört man eher wenn die menschen
hier an uns vorbeigehen dass sie auf
mike pence schimpfen dass sie auf den
republikanischen mehrheitsführer im
senat schimpfen mitch mcconnell weil
auch der sich gegen jump gestellt hat
also donald trump erntet was er gesät
hat und ich sage mal man muss sich große
sorgen machen um das land denn das was
an stimmungen an aufgeheizter stimmung
an wut vorhanden ist das wird ja nicht
irgendwie mit der amtseinführung von joe
biden in zwei wochen dann mal eben so
verschwinden sondern das wirft auch die
nächsten jahre bestimmen die
demonstranten haben jetzt gerade
angefangen zu singen gleich hört man
dass im hintergrund das sind ja es
klingt sehr sehr düster auch ein stück
weit wie wir sehen fahnen unter diesen
demonstranten die im grunde genommen
auch ein bisschen das gefühl geben als
wäre man hier auf gewalt aus die gelben
fahnen die im hintergrund zu sehen sind
steht drauf don't run on me tritt nicht
auf mich ich lasse mich nicht von dir in
irgendeiner weise unterdrücken das ist
so eine der flaggen die steht für die
freiheitsbewegung in wahrheit ist
natürlich eine hier eher rechte
teilweise rechtsextremistische bewegung
in den usa
und wir sehen auch fahnen auf denen
donald trump als rambo zu sehen ist mit
einem maschinengewehr in der hand und
dann auf einem panzer
er wird gewissermaßen als anführer als
befreier als kämpfer hier dargestellt
auf den flaggen und ich glaube das ist
auch die stimmung zumindest bei einigen
von denen die zu den
rechtsextremistischen gruppen hier in
den usa gehören die hierher gekommen
sind um randale zu machen einer ihrer
anführer der chef der braut boys ist
gestern oder vorgestern abend besser
gesagt festgenommen
vorgestern festgenommen worden
er musste die stadt verlassen er hat
kein recht mehr die stadt zu betreten
aber seine anhänger die gruppe der braut
weiß das ist eine miliz eine bewaffnete
miliz normalerweise die sind natürlich
hier auch in großer zahl aufgetreten
und man sieht wie haben sie sich
eigentlich gerüstet für
auseinandersetzungen die haben teilweise
schusssichere westen dabei sie haben
militärische helme dabei was sie nicht
dabei haben dürfen sind waffen das ist
hier im district of columbia noch einmal
verboten worden in den letzten tagen
aber es ist natürlich nicht
ausgeschlossen dass der eine oder andere
doch waffen mitgebracht haben könnte
also eine sehr angespannte lage
ich habe jetzt immer weiter geguckt auf
social media der kollege igor bobic von
der hafen post ist sehr fleißig ist
mittendrin dabei und hat gerade dieses
bild gezeigt getwittert und das zeigt
tatsächlich dass demonstranten in die
kamera des senats vorgedrungen sind und
einer hat sich auf den stuhl der
senatsvorsitzenden des fonds gesetzt und
ja bald eine faust noch ist dieser
mensch alleine dort aber es werden
wahrscheinlich weitere menschen
nachkommen wenn dort nicht bald die
polizei eingreift und das gebäude
geräumt darauf warten wir es gibt jetzt
hier fragen elmar ob es möglich ist die
andere seite des gebäudes zu zeigen ist
es hier möglich mal die position zu
ändern und vielleicht wird ein bisschen
näher heran zu gehen oder auf die andere
seite des gebäudes zu gelangen
das können wir leider nicht also wir
stehen auf der ostseite des kapitols das
ist die seite zwischen dem
kongressgebäude und dem obersten
gerichtshof dem ich gewissermaßen gleich
gegenüber stehe und die andere seite des
gebäudes das wäre die westseite die ist
in richtung washington monument in
richtung der großen malern der ja auch
die museen sind auch in richtung des
weißen hauses und des lincoln memorial
und auf dieser westseite des kapitols
sind natürlich schon alle vorbereitungen
getroffen worden in den letzten monaten
für die amtseinführung und zwanzigster
da stehen riesige tribünen auf denen
dann die ehrengäste natürlich alle unter
corona bedingungen dann platz nehmen
sollten
und auf dieser seite also auf der
anderen seite der westseite des kapitols
steht offenbar auch eine viel größere
zahl von demonstranten als hier hinter
uns es wird geschätzt dass insgesamt
mindestens 30 wenn ich sogar 50.000
demonstranten vom anhänger hier in der
stadt sind der größere teil von ihnen
auf der anderen seite die polizei hat
versucht auch die demonstranten davon
abzuhalten hier auf diese auf die
ostseite zu kommen das hat einen
einfachen grund das ist die seite hier
an der die fahrzeuge an der die kolonnen
die wagenkolonnen vorfahren an der
normalerweise auch die
kongressabgeordneten die senatoren oder
abgeordnete dann tatsächlich hier weg
gebracht werden können in sicherheit
gebracht werden könnten
das hat nicht geklappt das sind tausende
von demonstranten durch die polizei
linien durchgebrochen und haben wir
haben es gesehen hier eben auch die
entsprechenden treppenstufen besetzt da
sieht man noch mal die bilder wir
schwenken noch mal rüber die
abgeordneten und alle die im capitol
sind haben natürlich dennoch eine chance
das gebäude zu verlassen
es geht unter dem kapitol unterirdische
gänge tunnel die alle verbunden sind mit
den umliegenden kongress gebäuden dass
es sind die bürogebäude des
amerikanischen kongresses es gibt auch
sogar eine unterirdische seine u-bahn
unter dem kapitel die ebenfalls
verbunden ist mit den nachbargebäuden
das heißt es wäre ohne probleme möglich
die kongressabgeordneten den
vizepräsident alle im gebäude in
sicherheit zu bringen wenn es denn
notwendig ist wir wissen nicht genau wie
es schon so weit ist dass man das getan
hat aber müssen jetzt abwarten wie sich
die situation hier vor dem
kongressgebäude weiterentwickelt ich
kann auf jeden fall hier noch mal ein
bild zeigen dass auf social media auf
twitter geteilt wurde
wo man wirklich sehen kann dass es
zwischen den demonstranten und der
polizei zu handgreiflichkeiten gekommen
ist das wird von der seiten der polizei
pfefferspray gesprüht aber die
demonstranten antworten genau
mit einem ähnlichen ja sieht aus wie
pfefferspray oder einem ähnlichen
reizgas zumindest die virtuelle so
beruhigt sie schnell aber es ist eine
extrem aufgeheizte stimmung und wie ich
gerade schon gezeigt habe es sind
tatsächlich menschen vorgedrungen
die senatskammer um dort ihrem protest
ausdruck zu verleihen man kann auch
sagen sie haben das ganze gestürmt ich
würde jetzt noch mal kurz rüber schalten
zu unserer politikwissenschaftlerin
kathryn klüver es bruck die das ganze
auch beobachtet und vielleicht noch mal
einordnen kann für uns wenn wir die
leitungen so schnell gewechselt kriegen
vom klieversberg wenn wir noch mal auf
dieses jahr auf diesen etwas
merkwürdigen vorgang gucken dass donald
trump quasi seinen vize-präsidenten dazu
auffordert etwas gegen diese
präsidentschaftswahl zu tun
wie kann man das erklären dann müsste
doch eigentlich wissen dass das rein
rechtlich nicht möglich ist ja ganz
genau
es ist ein verfassungsbruch oder es wäre
ein verfassungsbruch also ist entspricht
die regeln für diese für diese im grunde
genommen homöopathische cremonesi am
heutigen montag in den usa kritisch
abfinden müssen
die sind bis aufs altgriechische
festgelegt das hat man heute morgen auch
schon gesehen als repräsentant des
kongress ist eine grundsatzfrage stellen
wollte wurde er sofort von dem
vize-präsidenten abgestraft das heißt
natürlich sind diese regeln festgelegt
aber wir haben von donald trump gelernt
über die letzten vier jahre und auch
durch die verschiedenen wahlkampf
episoden des präsidenten dass wir ihnen
regeln nicht zählen und das ist
natürlich so ging es los mit dem abbau
oder den raub auch an der amerikanischen
demokratie ist das erste politische
normen zerstört wurden nämlich wie
verhält man sich in einer demokratie
zueinander sowohl im institutionellen
gefüge hierbei eben auch untereinander
das heißt liebe regeln werden einen
präsidenten jump wenig wenig irritiert
haben er versucht ja im grunde genommen
wie ein spielplatz tyrann alle
möglichkeiten auszureizen nur ist es
natürlich jetzt gefährlich denn wir
leben nicht über einen alltäglichen
spielzeug tyrann spielplatz in libyen
vielleicht alle kennen sondern wir reden
über den mächtigsten mann der welt der
eben
und das hat er uns noch mal gesagt
50.000 60.000 menschen irgendwie
hauptstadt bringen kann wenn man so
möchte andere anhalten kann zu diesem
protest und das inmitten einer pandemie
wie in den usa 357 tote gefordert hat
ich habe heute auch natürliches ganze
verfolgt auch social media und es gibt
einen kollegen von der new york times
alex king sinken der hat getwittert was
trump dort gerade versucht ist eine
übernahme der demokratie oder quasi er
versucht die demokratie zu zerstören
würden sie auch so weit gehen in dieser
einschätzung ja das würde ich sofort
unterschreiben denn wie gesagt das
gehört alles zu der taktik die dieser
präsident nicht eben seit einem jahr
fährt sondern die untermauerung oder der
ddr der entzug des vertrauens in das
demokratische system und eben zwei nicht
nur also in die regeln und gesetze
sondern eben auch angenommen dass
gehörte von vornherein zu dem profil
dieses präsidenten
das hat ihm aber natürlich auch unter
seinen wlan guten und loyalen zuspruch
gewonnen denn das sind menschen in ganz
großen teil die sich ja verraten gefühlt
haben vom system auch vom demokratischen
system die nicht gehört wurden
donald trump hat es geschafft wähler zu
finden die quasi noch nie in ihrem
bisherigen leben an eine wahl ohne
getreten waren
die sowohl 20/16 wie aber daneben auch
im november 2020 zum teil zu acht mal an
die wahlurne getreten sind und das will
doch zeigen dass dieser umbruch prozesse
also dass dieser raubbau an der
demokratie an sich am system an sich
wird das wird folgen haben und diese
spaltung in der gesellschaft die wir
schon angesprochen haben
die existiert weiter und die wird es
auch für joe biden wenn er dann am 20
januar sein amt annehmen kann
schwierig machen das land zu einen und
auch politisch in die richtige in seine
richtung zu bringen
für die gerade erst einschalten wir
reden gerade live über die ereignisse in
washington am kapitol wo eigentlich
heute eine pro forma abstimmung ja
stattfinden sollte eine debatte in den
beiden kammern des kongresses im senat
und im abgeordnetenhaus
es geht doch
um die anerkennung der abstimmung der
wahlleute zur präsidentschaftswahl das
heißt eigentlich ein eher ein ritual als
tatsächlich ein wirklich wichtiger tag
aber donald trump hat seine anhänger
dazu aufgefordert zum kapitol zu ziehen
die haben das sehr wörtlich genommen und
haben jetzt tatsächlich teilweise das
kapitel gestürmt wir haben bilder
gesehen ich kann sich hier noch mal
zeigen auf meinem bildschirm dass
menschen im gebäude sind hier sehen wir
offenkundig ich weiß nichts die capitol
polizei ist oder andere bewaffnete
einheiten die mit gezogener waffe auf
eine tür zielen die sie auch auf dem
kundig verbarrikadiert haben
dh die stimmung ist angespannt
wenngleich wir noch keine berichte
darüber haben dass tatsächlich auch
geschossen haben wurde oder dass
menschen verletzt wurden trotzdem eine
sehr außergewöhnliche historische stunde
in washington
denn das kapitel gestürmt wurde das ist
so tatsächlich noch nie passiert und das
hat so wahrscheinlich doch auch niemals
kommen sehen schauen wir doch mal nach
georgia vielleicht um dass dieses thema
auch noch zu besprechen denn dort findet
eine oder fand gestern eine stichwahl
statt für zwei senatssitze die
demokratische partei sehr dringend
braucht um die mehrheit im senat quasi
zu haben mit der eine stimme der
vizepräsident in kanada harris die sie
dann dort hätte die frage ist jetzt aber
wie es dort aussieht können sie mir da
vielleicht tatsächlich sagen was dort
gerade die entwicklung in georgia sind
haben sie die verfolgt ja es laufen die
letzten auszahlungen für die stimmen die
dann gegebenenfalls den vermeintlichen
sieg des zweiten senats kandidaten
gestern haben wir schon ungefähr
genetisch zu später abendstunde haben
wir schon gesehen
das jahr des ersten afro-amerikanischen
senators aus dem bundesstaat georgia
gegen priester der früheren kirche von
martin luther king junior der ist an
seiner also erst erfolgreich gewesen er
sieht ist bestätigt worden
gewartet wird noch zur stunde auf den
ausgang der zweiten stichwahl für den
senat
da sind stehen sich zwei männer
gegenüber als auch der demokrat und
david perdu der republikaner
es war denkbar eng gegen ende des quasi
alles fernsehabend sie in den usa dort
werden zurzeit noch ausgezählt besonders
die briefwahlen ja der us militärs die
in giotto zu hause sind also die aber
auf der ganzen welt stationiert sind
aber es sieht doch so aus als würde sich
auch da der vorsprung führt john
ausbauen sodass noch wir warten auch die
stunde zu stunde auf das absolute ente
oder das amtliche endergebnis aber sieht
zumindest so aus als könne auch chance
auf der zweite demokrat in diesem rennen
in georgia die wahl für sich entscheiden
und das haben sie schon angesprochen
damit wäre die mehrheit der demokraten
auch im senat gewährleistet wenngleich
knapp also es müsste natürlich noch
einiges lernen kompromisse gemacht
werden mit den republikanern wenn es um
ausschüsse und diverse andere dinge
gehen aber es würde für einen beiden
bedeuten dass er dass vizepräsident karl
harris mit einer ganz anderen politik
ins land gehen können eben wir gerade
auch gesetzgeberisch viel ist absichern
können was präsident barack obama
besonders in der zweiten amtszeit nicht
hat leisten kann weil er eben einen
gespaltenen kongress hatte wenn wir noch
mal auf die aktuellen entwicklungen
schauen die wir gerade in washington
verfolgen können da kann ich nochmal
einen bild zeigen was der kollege frank
fort getwittert hat der ist kongress
reporter bei nbc news und er zeigt
tatsächlich das protestierende im senat
sind direkt im gebäude dort wo
normalerweise die senatoren sitzen
die stimmung sieht friedlich aus muss
man sagen die polizei versucht aber auch
nicht die menschen von dort so räumen es
sind ja ein gutes dutzend die es bis
dorthin geschafft haben die jetzt ein
bisschen ratlos herum stehen und nicht
genau wissen was sie dort eigentlich
machen sollen sie zumindest für mich aus
aber natürlich ist es eine situation die
eigentlich zur amerikanischen demokratie
nicht passt es gibt hier auch auf
twitter stimmen die sagen das ist ein
putschversuch und nein wir sind hier
nicht in venezuela sondern tatsächlich
in den usa und wir haben auch aktuelle
bilder von unseren
kollegen die wir jetzt mal auflegen
wollen um es das mal anzuschauen
also das war die situation vor dem
kapitol zahlreiche demonstranten davor
die dann versucht haben auch im laufe
der letzten stunden in das kapitol
einzudringen und ist es ihnen
tatsächlich gelungen die menschen sind
im capitol verteilt das ist das was wir
wissen sie haben das habe ich gerade
gezeigt bis in den senat hinein
geschafft es sind nicht hunderte wie
viele gebäude jetzt tatsächlich sind
können wir noch nicht sagen aber es sind
doch einige dutzende und die polizei so
scheint es zumindest nach den aussagen
unseres kompetenten mrt sind versucht wo
das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich versuchen
irgendwann dieses geburt gebäude zu
räumen
es gab außerdem eine ausgangssperre die
von der stadt washington verhängt wurde
ab 18 uhr heute abend darf niemand mehr
auf den straßen seien vermutlich um
ausschreitungen in der stadt zu
verhindern aber wir sehen einer großen
menschenmenge die sich ums kapitel herum
versammelt ich weiß nicht ob wir es noch
bilder sehen aus dem kapitol sonst würde
ich noch mal bei mir auf den rechner
schalten denn dort gibt es natürlich
über so schon wieder zahlreiche bilder
und videos die zeigen wie die menschen
dort im capitol sind es draußen aussieht
hier ein bild von steven müssen auch ein
kollege der die menschen länger zeigt
aber dort sehen wir auch steht polizei
versucht noch das ganze über kontrolle
zu bringen
das ganze ist eine ziemlich
unübersichtlichen situation muss man
sagen und wir schauen dass nochmal ob
meint bewege emma titel sind der dort
live vor ort ist allerdings auf der
ostseite du nicht ganz so viel los ist
und etwas neues sagen kann
was er gerade beobachtet der kommission
[Applaus]
einmal die leitung wechseln da ist er
kannst du uns sagen dies ist gerade bei
dir vor ort aussieht
ja die situation hat sich weiterhin
nicht entspannen das sind immer noch
demonstranten und nicht weniger am
kapitol zu sehen auch auf den stufen des
kapitols hier vorne sind auch einige es
haben viele trotzdem den platz des
geschehens jetzt schon verlassen
vor allen dingen familien mit kindern
ältere menschen sind hier weg gegangen
möglicherweise weil sie eine weitere
eskalation befürchten
wir müssen jetzt mittlerweile bestätigt
dass im capitol mehrere demonstranten
festgenommen worden sind wir wissen auch
dass tränengas tatsächlich eingesetzt
wurde um demonstranten aus dem kapitol
wieder zu vertreiben es wurden auch
waffen gezogen
tatsächlich haben beamte
sicherheitsbeamte im capitol mit ihren
waffen die türen gesichert hervor
möglicherweise eindringenden
demonstranten also es sind szenen die
man sich überhaupt nicht vorstellen kann
bei einer demokratie wie den usa die man
vielleicht eher aus ich sage es mal
salopp bananenrepubliken kennen würde
und das entscheidende dabei ist dass
diese demonstranten hierhergekommen sind
nicht einfach mal so
sondern weil sie über wochen und monate
angefüttert worden sind vom
amerikanischen präsidenten
höchstpersönlich der mit seinen lügen
dafür gesorgt hat dass die stimmung sich
weiter aufgeheizt hat viele hier sind
fest davon überzeugt dass donald trump
die wahl gewonnen hat und nicht joe
biden
sie nehmen nicht zur kenntnis oder
wollen nicht zur kenntnis nehmen dass
alle bundesstaaten die wahl offiziell
bereits zertifiziert haben und dass joe
biden der sieger dieser wahl ist wir
wissen nicht wie das heute abend hier
ausgehen wird
die polizei hat verstärkung gerufen die
stadt washington dc hat einen ausgangs
einer ausgangssperre heute abend ab 6
uhr verhängt das heißt man will dafür
sorgen dass die demonstranten nicht in
den straßen sind weil große
auseinandersetzungen befürchtet werden
welche rolle der präsident in den
nächsten stunden spielen wird ist
ebenfalls völlig offen
es gibt einen hinweis von amerikanischen
medien bestätigt dass ganz offenbar die
nationalgarde angefordert wurde um hier
am kapital auszuhelfen
um das kapital zu schützen gegen die
demonstranten aber diese anfrage
gerichtet an das amerikanische
verteidigungsministerium an das pentagon
wurde abgelehnt insofern wirft das die
frage auf inwieweit teile der regierung
möglicherweise nicht bereit sind hier
die sicherheit in washington wieder
herzustellen sowie show erst mal in die
kommentare die haben wir bis jetzt
sträflich vernachlässigt einfach weil
sich die ereignisse im capitol wirklich
überschlagen und das mit etlichen neuen
meldungen gibt auf einen kommentar
möchte ich eingehen von marco stangl der
uns als kosten beschreibt oder
bezeichnet vielen dank dafür sehr
freundlich es hätte kein tränengas
gegeben die demonstranten haben
feuerlöscher gesprüht das sind zwei
verschiedene videos und da wird es jetzt
wirklich wieder kompliziert einmal habe
ich ein video gezeigt draußen wo es
tatsächlich wahrscheinlich einen angriff
von demonstranten auf polizisten und
innen drin das ist richtig gab es auch
demonstranten die mit feuerlöschern
besprüht haben aber das sind zwei
verschiedene sachen die wir beide
gezeigt haben ist es toll marco wenn du
besser aufpasst dann musst du uns nicht
so unfreundlich hier in den kommentaren
beschimpfen die frage die ich mir stelle
im at wissen was kann dieser protest
jetzt tatsächlich bewirken also die
debatte ist abgebrochen worden
das heißt sie muss vertagt werden bis
die situation wieder beruhigt ist im
capitol aber mehr als um einen tag kann
es sich eigentlich nicht handeln oder ja
das sollte man zumindestens hoffen
vielleicht fühlen sich auch einige
abgeordnete die vorher noch der meinung
waren man müsse
donald trump ihr weiter unterstützen bei
dieser beglaubigung der wahl vielleicht
fühlen einige dieser abgeordnete dass
man zu weit gegangen ist in dem was
passiert cruz der anführer der gruppe
der senatorin die hier heute eben die
wahlergebnisse in frage stellen wollten
bzw schon gestellt haben vorhin der hat
vorhin getwittert es gibt keinerlei
rechtfertigung für gewalt von irgendwem
das hat er zwar getwittert aber
gleichzeitig musste er sich wie andere
abgeordnete hier in sicherheit bringen
im capitol und im grunde genommen wirft
dass die
frage auf ob man die geister auch wieder
los wird die man selber gerufen hat die
man selber aufgewiegelt hat in den
letzten wochen und monaten auch ted cruz
dem man nachsagt dass er vielleicht in
vier jahren als präsidentschaftskandidat
antreten will der muss sich fragen wie
das hier weitergehen soll
also ich glaube trotzdem unterm strich
dass wenn die kongress gespräche
beziehungsweise sitzung fortgesetzt
werden kann dann morgen vielleicht wenn
nicht heute abend dann wird es am ende
dennoch eine zertifizierung eine
beglaubigung der wahl von joe biden
geben er würde dann an amds eingeführt
werden am 20 januar 12 uhr mittags
ehrlich die amtszeit von donald trump
und jetzt kommt das aber keiner weiß was
donald trump innerhalb dieser zwei
wochen noch alles tun wird er ist nach
wie vor der amerikanische präsident und
der oberste befehlshaber des
amerikanischen militärs und es gibt
einen neuen tweet von seiner seite den
ich auch mal hier kurz zeigen kann
er ruft alle am us capitol dazu auf
friedlich zu bleiben keine gewalt mit
ausrufezeichen
und er schreibt denkt dran wir sind die
partei das land order also das recht und
gesetze respektiert das gesetz und
unsere tollen männer und frauen in blau
also die polizistinnen vielen dank der
motive sind für sie glaubhaft hältst du
diesen aufruf zum friedlichen protest
oder hast du vielleicht einmal dass es
in den klippen
ja ich glaube es ist sie mir ein stück
weiterentwickeln weil er kein
unterschied gemacht hat zwischen seinen
anhängern die aus politischen gründen
tatsächlich ihn unterstützt haben die
ihn gewählt haben und denen die bereit
sind gewalt auszuüben hier in den usa
allen voran die milizen
er hat ja immer gesagt zu den milizen
sie sollen im grunde um sich
bereithalten und dabei offen gelassen
was er damit meint die können sich von
ihm ermächtigt fühlen und umgekehrt
fühlte er sich ganz offenbar ermächtigt
von seinen anhängern und natürlich auch
von den 74 millionen wählern die auch
ihn gewählt haben aber es ändert nichts
an der tatsache den anderen im rennen
die beiden haben über 80 millionen
menschen gewählt er ist der sieger
dieser wahl
und man kann nur hoffen dass sich das
ganze in den nächsten tagen friedlich
auflöst und tatsächlich joe biden um 20
januar vereidigt wird
eine frage die man stellen kann ist
warum die nationalgarde nicht schon ja
das ganze abgesichert hat relative sind
nicht dort gestanden hat der protest war
ja angekündigt ja die nationalgarde
wurde gestern gerufen um die straßen von
washington zu sichern hier im capitol
ist eigentlich die capital police
zuständig und eben auch andere
bundessicherheitsbehörden die hier den
schutz des kapitols gewährleisten
und wenn man die nationalgarde hier
einsetzen will dann braucht man dazu
eben die zustimmung des amerikanischen
pentagon des verteidigungsministeriums
und nach den quellen berichten in
amerikanischen medien fuhren ist diese
zustimmung ja offenbar nicht gegeben
worden also man ist hier also die
polizei des kapitols des kongresses ist
hier zum guten teil auf sich allein
gestellt und ich habe gerade aus der
regie gesagt bekommen dass hier neue
bilder haben die doch sehr eindrücklich
zeigen was dort im capitol gerade los
ist noch nicht die liegen noch nicht vor
dann kann ich aber zumindest sagen dass
der minderheiten führer der republikaner
im repräsentantenhaus kevin mccarthy die
gewalttätigen proteste auf fox news
unamerikanisch genannt hat das ist somit
das schlimmste schimpfwort quasi für
einen republikaner sie müssen sofort
aufhören seinen angaben zufolge wurden
dort auch schüsse abgegeben das habe ich
auch aus einer anderen quelle
mitbekommen das heißt die situation im
capitol bleibt weiter angespannt und
jetzt schaue ich mal ob vielleicht uns
jetzt die bilder vorlegen regie habt ihr
was leider noch nicht da müssen wir
einfach mal weiter schauen wie sich die
situation entwickelt was was glaubst du
denn emma also was wäre jetzt die
normale das normale vorgehen der polizei
eigentlich müsste man doch damit rechnen
dass dort mal jetzt einige
hundertschaften eindrücken und dem
ganzen spuk ein ende bereiten oder
ja ich glaube was die polizei machen
würde ist dass sie eben hier ein
bisschen short fonds macht damit man
ganz klar sieht dass kräfte jedes
kapitel schützen würden und noch mal
hier sind jetzt schon viel weniger
menschen als noch vor einer stunde der
fall war es gehen viele ob sie nach
hause fahren was auch immer für viele
auch das haben wir hier vorhin von
demonstranten gehört die an uns vorbei
weggingen vom kapitol dass sie gesagt
haben jetzt habt ihr mal gesehen wie wir
das alles finden was da passiert im land
und dass diese wahl gestohlen wird so
haben sie es gesagt was natürlich nicht
der fall ist weil es eben keinerlei
beweise für irgendwelche größeren
wahlbetrug in den usa gibt also diese
menschen sind vielleicht nach hause
gegangen und das bedeutet dass ein
harter kern nur hier ist und das wäre
dann der punkt wo die polizei wo die
sicherheitskräfte möglicherweise in der
lage sind das kapital wieder ich sag mal
frei zu räumen auch die stufen des
kapitols freizuräumen und dann würde man
wenn man die sitzung des kongresses
wieder aufnimmt sicherlich einen
weiteren sicherheits kreis um dieses
gebäude ziehen um sicherzustellen dass
das gleiche nicht noch einmal passiert
so das ist eigentlich schon fast ja
voraussehen
wir hätten es kommen sehen das geht
natürlich die ersten
verschwörungstheorien im cat ihr könnt
euch das sparen solche merkwürdigen
sachen zu posten wie zum beispiel dass
das antifa anhänger werden die jetzt als
in einer falschen flagge aktion sich als
tramp anhänger ausgeben würden um dort
quasi ja das ansehen der
republikanischen partei zu beschädigen
das ist glaube ich und das können wir
von hier aus sehen relativ unzweifelhaft
dass dem nicht so ist und diese mögen ja
dass das antifa anhänger bezahlt kann
ich vielleicht auch noch mal sagen
daniel das kann ich auch noch mal sagen
daniel weil wir haben ja mit den
menschen hier auch geredet teilweise
wurden wir auch heftig beschimpft das
sind keine antifa anhänger
das sind trump anhänger das sind
teilweise auch anhänger von bewaffneten
milizen das sind teilweise
rechtsextremisten richtig nicht alle
einige davon sind rechtsextremisten aber
trotzdem ist in trump anhänger in erster
linie das hier ist keine false flag
operation
aber wir werden die situation als will
ich weiter beobachten bei uns auf der
zdf heute du brauchst ist noch mal ein
paar minuten um sich vorzubereiten weil
natürlich das heute journal wird um 21
die entwicklungen in washington
aufgreifen weiter berichten deswegen
möchte ich euch dann doch mal ins gute
alte fernsehen zurück schicken natürlich
aber auch wenn ihre karten mehr habt
könnt ihr das auf zdf.de in der
mediathek gucken und dort weiter
verfolgen
wir machen jetzt hier erstmal den sagt
dicht für heute es war ein ziemlich
spannender abend der wahrscheinlich die
nächsten stunden auch noch weiter
spannend sein wird ich bitte euch alle
ruhig zu bleiben auch in den kommentaren
auch in den nächsten stunden sind
natürlich besorgniserregende bilder aber
es ist nicht das ende der welt
ich bin sicher dass die situation dort
bald wieder unter kontrolle ist und in
diesem sinne sagen jetzt erst mal
schönen guten abend noch macht's gut
bis bald